provide safe shelter to domestic
violence and human trafficking survivors
and their children and it is time for
their annual fundraising event Once Upon
A Gala and here to tell us more is the
CEO of shade tree Linda Perez welcome
back Linda and thank you for having me
back I'm so excited to be here this is
so great shade tree is one of my
favorite organizations in town you do so
much for the women and children of this
community I hit a little bit of what you
do can you explain how the funds that
will be raised at your event are going
to go to help shade tree yes absolutely
and thank you for having us and we are
so super excited about having this Gala
it's been since October 2019. wow so
this is our largest fundraiser and we're
so excited because this funding it does
go to help us provide case management to
our clients who are domestic violence
human trafficking and homeless women
children and their pets because of our
partner with Noah's Animal House so the
funding is very crucial to the work that
we do and we're so excited to finally
um gather and have a good time it's
going to be a great time and it's
happening at Resorts World so tell us
about the theme it's like a fairy tale
theme what's going to be happening there
yeah so our theme is Once Upon A Gala
and the whole premise of that and the
idea is that happily ever after looks
different for everyone and everybody's
story matters and that we have the
opportunity to write our different
stories you know for our clients and not
everybody's story is the same so we're
super excited it's going to be a zuke
nightclub oh my God right isn't that
amazing gonna be so fun and you guys are
going to have like drinks and and food
and all and entertainment tell us about
the entertainment yes so well one JJ
Snyder is our Mistress of Ceremonies
nice so we're very excited to have her
Patrick in the lvb is our entertainment
for the night but we have so many silent
auction items you know that are are
going to be available like a Luke Bryant
package it's so many great things Mystic
Mona will be there so many things and if
you can attend an event our silent
auction item will be live so once on our
social media so please check us out
you'll definitely have to check that out
I was looking at some of the items and
there are some great things so you can
still get tickets they start at how much
at 4 25 and that's for our secret garden
Soiree and then our regular Gala price
amazing Once Upon A Gala is happening
tomorrow night make sure you check out
seven at Resorts World at zook nightclub
for more information visit
theshadetree.org Kendall all right it is